if you have been following along with
this series of tutorials you may have
noticed that there is no undo within
chimera other than the undo selection
feature
in this final video we will explore
three workarounds for this issue using
the hemoglobin structure for hhb
we can use the command line to save a
structure's position in the graphics
window
let's say you are ready to begin
exploring this structure but don't want
to lose the current view
the solution is to type into the command
line save pause p1 and press enter
this command defines the current
position as position 1 in chimera's
memory
now you can safely explore the structure
in the graphics window
to return to the original position all
you need to do is enter into the command
line reset p1
you can extend this basic technique to
save more than one position just label
your second position as p2 your third is
p3 and so on as you define more
positions
following the save pause command you can
also type names that are more specific
than the p plus integer naming system
that i just demonstrated in fact you can
type whatever name you want
for example we could save this position
using the command save pass
since we are focusing in on a particular
heme group
the reset format is the same as before
we just enter into the command line
reset
to recover the initial position
for this workaround it is key that you
are working within a session file that
has previously been saved using save as
chimera's file directory makes it easy
to identify such files
in this list files marked with an
extension have been saved beforehand
while those without an extension have
not
with that knowledge let's open the
hemoglobin structure we have been
looking at
the idea behind this workaround is to
save the session as you modify the
structure
let's say we go to actions ribbon and
turn on ribbon edging
now we can go to file and save the
change
then we decide to select the heme groups
and change their depiction
to sphere
but at this point you realize that you
like the heme groups better in their
original depiction so rather than saving
this change the next step is to close
the session
upon reopening it the heme groups are
restored but the ribbon edging remains
because we had previously saved that
change
in this way we can effectively create an
artificial undo within chimera
finally we can use chimera's animation
interface to store structure depiction
modifications before making any changes
let's start by taking a snapshot of the
structure in its default state
now we go to actions
color
all options and selectively color the
ribbons cyan
then we stop and take a snapshot of the
result
for our next change we will select the
heme groups
and color them red
we then take another snapshot of the
result
next we select chain a
edge its ribbons
and snapshot the result
now we have created a history of our
depiction changes within the animation
interface
by left clicking on the snapshots we can
easily recover past states of the
structure and access any of the
depictions created along the way